サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
今日はちょっとスライド数が大きくなったので
できるだけ早く進めます
私はこのスライドにない説明しないしていきますから
皆様はこの私よりもしかすると日本語をご存じだと思いますからね
スライドの文章を読んでみてください
たまに打ち間違い 漢字の変換間違いとかありますけどね
これもご自分の知恵で訂正しながら読んでみてください
一回書いたら二回見ないという私の性格ですからね
さっと書いて終わって
はい さようならと まあ今日の話はこの幸せっていうことで
幸せの育て方なんですね
で まあこのテーマですね
皆様 なんか暗い 見えないね
私の心と同じですね はい
まずはな幸福について
まあ私はこの幸せ 幸福って
まああまり言葉に気にしない
何でも使えます 私たちの定義って
いわゆる俗世間の定義ですね
これは私にいろいろアイデアを出してくれて
それをそのままパクって入れたんです
まあ読んでみてください
私の読めないものもありますね
こんなものですね 私たちの幸せの定義というのは
気持ちいい 美味しい 楽な感じね
楽しい 明るい感じ なんだらかんだとかね
軽い感じ ホッとした感じ
のびのびのんびりなんとか
それから楽な感覚 心地よい刺激
あるいはまた別にまた言葉を変えているんですね
気持ちいいというね まあ気持ちっていうのは
まあ一応これはまあ一応表現ですからね
代わりに何とか  そういう感じでね
これもよくわかりますね
そういう体が楽だとかね
ずっと立っていて 椅子に座った時とかね
そういう体の中からもたまに楽しみ
楽を感じちゃうんですね
それで感覚的な刺激というね
まあ結構我々は刺激を求めて生きているんだからね
その時も感情的に興奮してしまいますね
また私たちの定義 また続きます
気が楽だ 休み 休みのく働いて
まあ今日定年退職とかね
まあこれ楽しく思いますかね
これ私に送ってくれた文章をそのまま載せたんだからね
それは私はちょっと疑問に思いますけどね
休みなく働いて  1 日休んだとこはまあ楽しくなるかもしれません
楽しい今日はとかね あまり定年退職って楽しいんですかね
楽しくないと思いますけど
あ 楽しい みんなとおしゃべり
大しゃべり  それはよくわかりますね
お金がたくさん入ったとかね
給料日とかね ボーナスとかね
宝くじの当選 それはなかなかないね
そういうものを俗世間で私たちは楽しい幸福というふうに定義するものなんですね
感情的な浮き沈み まあこれはよくわからない
私も  こんなものは幸せであると私たちは思っている
それについて私は全然何も喋りません
何か言ったったら悪口で終わっちゃいますからね
皆様の幸福を壊していいわけじゃないんだからね
で これは私たちの定義
次に幸福 仏教の定義  それ勉強するためにいらっしゃったんだからね
私たちの定義は我々は知ってるんですね
それは土台にして話を続けていきます
幸福も如実に観察して分析する
今まで私たちの定義のセクションではあまり大雑把ですね
はっきりしないんですね
なんとなく曖昧 何でもいいやという感じの幸福論でしたからね
なんかあまりも何でしたっけね
空気のようになんか取れなくなっちゃうんですね
ではなくて この我々は幸福を感じる
幸福といっても 普通に楽しみにしてください
普通の幸せを感じる まあそれもわからなかったら
ああ よかったって感じるでしょ
ああ よかったっていう感じが感じた
あれなんですね このわけのわからない幸福
幸せ なんだらかんだり言ってるのはね
よく日常生きている場合では
ああ よかったって気分には結構入る
味わうんですね これなんですね
だから あんなダラダラダラダラたくさん考えなくてもね
ああ よかったって 例えばお腹が空いてるとご飯
ああ よかったとかね と感じちゃうんですね
それをブッダのこの科学的な目でしっかりと客観的に
ありのままに見なくちゃいけないんです
はい それで一番最初のポイントはこれから難しいんです
よかったではなくて よくなかったということになるかもしれません
で 心に起こる現象 幸福っていうのは
これははっきりしてほしいんです
これ 大事なポイントなんです
幸福は心にあるんです
財産 名誉 権力 家族 友人
ペット 美容 健康 仕事などモノではありません
我々すごい思っちゃうんですよ
可愛いワンちゃん 誰かからプレゼントでもらったら
気に入っちゃって ああ
よかった ワンちゃんのおかげで幸せやと
嘘です ワンちゃんプレゼントでもらった時の心の起きた
あの気持ち自体が幸せです
また その人が自分には猫
犬を飼う全部条件もあるのに
もう面倒くさいですね
これから散歩させさせなくちゃいけないし
面倒見なくちゃいけないし
もう家を出る時も気をつけなきゃ
大変やと思っちゃうと
その人はまあ可愛いことは可愛いんだけどとかね
その人は幸せ感じてないんですね
なんか義務を感じているんですね
だからワンちゃんはワンチャンでどうってことないんです
だからワンちゃんもらったら楽しくなるか
義務感を感じて大変だ
これからと感じるかと
それ心の問題なんです
ワンちゃんのせいだと思わないでください
ああ 楽しいと思った人は
ワンちゃんのおかげで楽しくなっちゃったとかね
あ これって大変なものもらっちゃって
これから大変だと思った人は
このこいつのせいで私がなんかすごい仕事多く増えましたよと
お前のせいやと ワンちゃんに当たらないでください
それだけなんです それをものすごい気をつけてください
これだけで皆様方は仏教的な生き方をする羽目になります
お金でおかげで幸せではないんです
お金のせいにしないでください
財産があって私は幸せやと思ったら
これ間違いなんです なぜならば
財産のせいでものすごいひどい目に遭う人もいるんですよ
だから物が幸せを与えてくれるならば
幸せというのはいたって単純です
計算できます  10万円の幸せ
この程度やと １００万円の幸せ
この程度やとかね まあ普通の数学者に計算することはできます
普通の心理学者に そうすると WHO でね
世界の幸福基準を作っちゃってね
この値値になるようにしてくださいと
そうすると 車からのこれぐらい幸福
お金 １０万円からこれぐらいの幸福
マイホームあったらこれぐらいが計算すれば WHO の値は飛んでいる
ああ 私は幸せやと思うことできますよ
それだったら あの世界で一番幸せな国ってどこですか？知ってます？ブータンでしょ
あれ すごい豊かな国じゃないんです
普通 質素な生き方をしているんです
でも 国民が感じる幸せ度は世界一なんです
不思議です だから王もいるんだけどね
王様いたっても ただなんか国民ってみんなとすごい仲良く仲良しで
で 最近かなね 子供が生まれて
まあみんな来て 子供をお祝いしてね
だからこの王の夫婦もね
すごく喜んじゃって みんなに赤ちゃんをあげて
もうみんなもう喜んでますよ
なんか王様だからもう近寄れない
それないんですね みんな一緒に仲良く
実は私はその このお嬢様王家のね
飛行機で見たこともありますよ
ちょっと隣ではなくて
次の席に座っててね すごくなんか
うん 王やらあれやこれ何もないんだなとかね
すごく丁寧で謙虚で優しくて
気づいたのは いつでも後ろから誰か誰か来てね
そこで膝まずいて なんとか何とか喋って
また行く また来て なんとか何とか喋ってまた行くとかね
それでいたら なんかブータンのなんたらかんたらですってね
だからこのすごい幸せだなと思いますよ
私も だから物ではないね
ということは 我々には誰にだって幸せになる権利が生じるんですよ
金が幸せだと思っちゃうと権利がないんですね
だって狂暴な連中 金を全部奪い取ってるんだから
一般人には金がないんです
皆様も金持ちの顔をしているんだけどね
そんな金持ちじゃないと思いますよ
なんとか間に合ってるだけでしょうに
私は嘘は言えませんだから
私は日本に長いんだから
金のやりくりね 結構大変気をつけていますよ
だから金で幸せだと思っちゃうと
もう私たちは全部もう払い箱になっちゃうんですね
インドみたいにザミンダールというシャトリア
そこのね 地主 土地を持っていたら幸せやと思ったらね
すごい乱暴な言い方になっちゃうんですね
そうすると はい 物ではありませんとまず覚えてください
ちょっと長すぎ このフレーズは心に起こる楽しみ感
喜びが幸福だと理解するんです
心に起こる なんかなんか何か変な気持ちが起こるんですね
我々 言葉でよかったっていうのは
あの気持ちなんですね
このよかったという言葉にそれ入ってないんです
本当は だから言葉と本当に思うものはいつでもかなりずれるんですよ
例えば子供が宿題終わったよと言ったら
お母さんはよかった それは別に幸福を表す言葉じゃないんです
私はよかったっていうことは
もう人を馬鹿にするために使うんです
あ よかったねとかね 馬鹿なことやっちゃってね
これ叱りたいんですね
でもあまりそういう単語が出てこないんで
何のことをやってるのとかね
私たちの訓練でそういう言葉出てこない
これもうとにかくネタに仕上げる
ああ よかったねとかね
だからこのよかったっていう単語に幸福を
単語で幸福を表現するわけは難しいね
幸福を作る道具が幸福だと誤解しないようにと
金土地の家族財産 なんだらかんだらはこの道具なんですね
包丁がおいしいというバカがいるんですかね
包丁とまな板は立派なもので
本当にごちそうですと
立派なまな板と立派な包丁があったからといってね
それは道具ですよ 道具で腕を振るってごちそうを作らなくちゃいけない
そういうことで よく人間がこの道具が目的にしているんですね
世の中狂ってるのはそういうわけなんですよ
はい もっと難しくしましょうね
前のスライドはよくわかりやすいね
だから難しくしないと
六根感覚器官ですね 六処
これは対象 それを勉強しましょう
眼耳鼻舌身意は六根です
体にあるものですね パーリ語でサラートと言います
色声香味触法は六処 チャーラム
まあサラヤ チャーラ 別な単語もありますけどね
それで目に色が入るとかね
これは専門用語だから
まあ理解してください
目に入るものは色という
耳に耳が感じるものには声という
そこで心で感じるものには法という
法と言ったって ブッダに説かれた真理というわけじゃないんですね
現象 物事っていう意味なんですね
その場合は 頭でいろんなことを考えたりするでしょう
頭には対象が入るんですね
心 耳に音が触れると感覚が生めるでしょ
そのように頭にもいろいろアイディアが触れると思考が回転するんです
情報は感覚器官に触れることは即ファッサというんですね
順番に理解してください
この体に六 六根がある
六根に六つの対象が触れる
触れたことにはファッサという専門用語を使います
なんでこの専門用語といってもごく一般的に使う単語ですけどね
で それをそこで生命はスタートするんですよ
この触れることで ものにものを触れることで生命じゃないんですね
この六感にものが触れる
六感の場合 一番でっかい感覚器官は肉体なんです
肉体って感覚器官なんで
ものすごくでっかい 目っていうのは小さいんですね
耳ものすごい小さいんです
鼻っていったっても このあの
能力 嗅ぐ能力あるところは
嗅覚あるところはほんのちっちゃいんです
で 舌も同じですよ 舌大きいんだけど
舌全体で味は感じませんね
じゃあ帰ってから実験してみてください
舌の裏に何か触れて入れてみるとかね
一番先っぽに何か入れてみるとかね
例えば先っぽ何も感じませんよ
上ですよ 上 それまた場所
苦味 甘み いろいろ感じる場所もまたまた決まっていて
で ほんのりスペースなんですね
ベロの周りは何も感じません
ベロの裏 何も感じません
先端にも何も感じません
感じると思ったら あれは溶けちゃってね
感じるところに行っちゃいますね
その時は感じますけど
はっきり言うとそういうところを感じる
だから小さいスペースですよ
それに体 足の指先から頭の上までかなりのところがあるんですね
で そちらにものを触れる
椅子やらもう触るものが触れる
その場合も 人間の場合は指先
ものすごい感覚識別能力もすごくあるんでしょ
そこで我々生き物っていうのは
この触れることを感じる
ものにものを触れることはどうったことないんです
例えば鉛筆が転がっちゃって
このパソコンに触れてしまう
どうったことない 鉛筆も何も感じないし
パソコンも何も感じないんです
触れることを感じる 触れたら感じる
これヴェーダナーというんですね
六種の感覚ヴェーダナーを
これでヴェーダナー六種になっちゃうんですね
体に感じる 鼻で感じる
ベロで感じる 耳で感じる
目で感じるとかね 心で感じる
だから六種のヴェーダナーなんですね
パーリ語でチャックヴェーダナー
ソータヴェーダナー ガーナヴェーダナー
ジハヴェーダナー カーヴェーダナー
マノヴェーダナーというんですね
この感じたこと 六種の感覚
スッカ 楽 クゥ ドッカ フーカ
不楽 ウペッカーと瞬間に分けてしまいます
私たちは感じただけで終わらないんですよ
感じたものは 3つにカテゴライジングするんです
良い感覚 悪い感覚とどちらでもない感覚に判断できないか
感じたんだけど判断できない
だから不苦不楽 これ瞬時に起こるんです
例えばベロに何か入れちゃった
そしたらすぐ苦 あ 嫌だ
もう嫌だと感じて判断して終わり
ベロの上に入れたものは何か甘い
甘くてよかったとかね
わかりやすい苦を基準にして
対照的に判断が起きます
この判断というのは科学的じゃないんです
だから心の世界は物理科学とはまるっきり違いますよ
だから物理科学だけ知っている人にとっては
心っていうのは曖昧で
もう研究できんやと 数学的に分析することはできないんです
これちょっと説明しなきゃわからないね
私たちはこの苦 苦しみを基準にしているんですよ
みんなわかってないんです
この自分が苦しみというこの尺度を持っていて
それに合わせるんです
新しい感覚を そういうことで
このレラティビティオブハピネスというね
この幸せの相対性が現れてくるんです
今の瞬間の苦と比較して
次の感覚を苦 楽 不苦不楽として決定します
だから何か感じたら その前にすごく苦を感じていたならば
この今感じたものはあれほど苦ではありません
そうすると これ楽やと思う可能性はあります
今の瞬間 何の苦も感じていない
次に感じたものは これは苦しいやと思う可能性もあります
例えば 体に六処どこかにえ？ という対象が触れたとしましょう
ある時はこれ楽しいという
え 触れたら ある時は触れてる
これ苦しいという だから比較する元になる苦なんですね
問題は そういうわけで
この基本的な苦が苦で比較するんだけど
よくやるのは今の気持ち
今の気持ちで比較するんです
この今の気持ち 終わっちゃったんです
例えば ある気持ちでいる
ある気持ちでいると 何か耳にすごい音が入ったんですね
前の気持ちは消えたんだけど
この前の気持ちに比較して
今入ってきた音はこれはうるさいねとか
苦で決めちゃうんです
そこでその音はそのままある
そして別な音が聞こえる
あ 面白い とその時判断する
面白くないかも 普通は
でも今感じているあのうるさいという感覚に比較すると
あちらの方がマシですね
それでそれは楽っていうことにしちゃうんです
だからもっと何かかっこよい言葉にします
で 私の幸福から苦しみやらなんだらかんだらでも今の気持ち次第やと
今の気持ちで幸福か不幸かと判断するんです
まあ例えば 自分の子供が遊んでくれる時は幸福を感じるでしょ？決まってない
自分がすごい真剣に大事なことをやっている
その時 子供がノコノコ来て遊びましょうと言うんですね
その時 うるさい 後にして下さいと
今は忙しいからと その時子供が邪魔なんですね
ということは苦ですね
いわゆる不幸なんですね
だから今の状態で幸不幸が変わってしまいます
子供がいて幸福やというふうなフレーズは当たらな
もう当たりません もう間違いなんです
我々そうです いつでも子供がいると幸せとかね
あれがあると幸せ そんな一定して幸せはないんです
子供がいて幸せという人も
子供がうるさいやという時もありますよ
これがこの相対性なんです
どうしますかね どうしますか？ではどうすることもできん
これ理解してください
今まであった幸福に対する邪見を捨ててください
幸福っていうのは相対的で
比較して対照的に判断するものなんです
だから定めたフレーズ言えないんだと
私に子供がいるゆえに私が幸せですと
あれは俗世間が言ってる間違った言葉なんです
私に子供がいる 時に幸せを感じる
時にうるさいと感じる
時にはいない方がよかったと感じる場合もありますよと
私にペットがいる 時に幸せを感じる
特に面倒くさいうるさいとか
いない方が良かったと思うとかね
そういうことでしょう
人生は 皆様の旦那にしたっても同じくっちゃでしょ？奥さんにしたって同じことでしょ
あ 奥さんがいて ああ いつでも幸せ
そんなことはあり得ません
私はうちの旦那のおかげでずっと幸せでいるんだ
それは嘘を言うなよと
それは嘘です いつでもこの幸福感
不幸感というのは瞬間瞬間流れていくんです
だから結婚して 旦那さん
この人と結婚できてよかった
幸せだという奥さんも
なんでこういう人と結婚したのかいと思う時もあります
男もああいう人を見つけて結婚でよかったと
よりによってひどい人を選んだもんだなとかね
思う時もあります だから仏教はこの観念的な
世の中の哲学者 思想家が言っている言葉に乗りません
そして いつでも具体的に現実的に物事を見ていくんです
はい それが我々の世界なんです
幸福の世界 スッカとウペッカーを基準にするバージョンもあります
だからこの必ず苦だけではなくて
楽もウペッカーっていうのは不苦不楽ですね
それぞれ基準にする 皆さんはよくもこのややこしいことを瞬間瞬間やってますよ
説明するとえらいややこしい
難しいね でもよくやってます
これやらない人間がいません
生命はやってます いつでもこれ複雑なこと
だから 今っていうのはほんのちょっとの前
今の感覚がある すべて無常だから
次の感覚が生まれる そうすると
この次に生まれた感覚をすでに消えた感覚と比較する
比較して価値判断に入れる
苦楽 不苦不楽という ややこしいんだったらこれやらないでください
これから やってるでしょうに
そこで今はまあ不苦不楽で
まあ楽しくもないし 苦しいわけでもなくていると
何か体に六処に触れる
そしたらびっくりしちゃって
あ びっくりとかね なんでびっくりしたんだよ
前は不苦不楽状態だったからね
はい 次 面白い現象があります
今 苦を感じている 仏教用語で苦を感じている
次のことも苦を感じる
次にも苦を感じる こうなってくると
もう面倒くさい 不苦不楽にする
それを やってない？やってますよ
または風邪が引き始める
あー調子が悪いと嫌だなとかね
と思っちゃうでしょ でも次の瞬間も風邪引いたままで
次の瞬間も風邪引いたままで
そうすると まあいいや
こんなことはと放っておかない？放っておく
最初は鼻が日本語で何て言いますか
ランニングノーズというのは鼻
鼻水が出ちゃうと あ いやだ
これはとかね でもずっと一日中鼻水出ているんですよ
それからまあ別に今日はまあ本当に鼻水が出ているということで
まあそれは不苦 まあ仕方がないと
嫌だ嫌だっていうこともなくなってるんです
だから 苦苦苦苦になってくると
不苦不楽にしたりする場合もあります
ということは 苦に慣れてしまう
鈍感になるんですかね
それ言ったのは この仏教用語でいう聖なる真理としていう苦は
スーッと宇宙法則としてあるものだから
鈍感になっているんですね
だから生命は悟れないということになっているんです
頑張らないと 感覚は楽
楽になると 次の判断は不苦不楽になります
楽の場合同じですよ じゃあ音楽を聴いている
楽しい 次の一秒も楽しい
次の一秒も一秒一秒 楽しい
楽しい 楽しいで どんどん普通になっちゃうんですね
それから不苦不楽が続くと
次に苦になっちゃう ああ
まあうるさい もうやめましょうと
音楽はと   例えば 30分音楽を聴こうと
まあプレイリスト作ってもう流しちゃう
最初の曲はまあ気分がいいなとかね
こうやってもう調子 何て言いますかね
もう取りながらもう聴いていて
体も振りながら まあ 2曲目もなんとか
もう 3曲目になってくると
どんどん普通になっちゃって
4曲目になってくるとやっぱりうるさい
やめましょうと プレイリスト全部終わってないんです
私の場合は 1曲も終わらないんで
途中でやめるんです こういう風に慣れると
慣れてしまうと なんか幸せを感じなくなっちゃうんですね
日本人が日本というのは素晴らしい国であると発見するのは外国に行った時でしょ
なぜ日本にいていてもう慣れちゃったんですね
何でも普通に感じるんですね
普通に感じると 次に文句言いたくなっちゃうんですね
あれが良くない これが良くないと
それで外国に行ってみて
1週間ぐらい歩いてみて
あれ 日本って何でも完璧しっかりできてるんだと
だからまあそういうことなんですよ
不幸 不楽から不幸 不楽
不幸 不楽の場合は ほとんど次は苦の判断になります
これは皆様にも実験できると思います
不幸 不楽っていうのは
まあ別に退屈的な まあ楽しくもない
苦しくもない 次の瞬間も次の瞬間も
長く 1時間もその気分になってくると
もう嫌になってる この何とかしなくちゃ
もう嫌だとかね 不幸 不楽は苦に変わってるんですね
それで楽の感覚も楽 楽
楽になっちゃうと 不幸
不楽になっちゃって苦
苦になっちゃうんです
苦の感覚は苦 苦だったら不幸
不楽になっちゃって それから楽にならないんです
それだけは 不幸 不幸 不楽
不幸 不楽になってくると
もうそれに嫌だ これをまた苦になっちゃうんです
だからパターンそういうパターンなんです
そういう風に何でもなんか変な流れな
何一つも一定していない
皆様今日来たのはね すごい変わらない
安定した幸福 何なのかと知りたくてでしょ
うん そういうことです
幸福は それ知ったらそれが幸福
本当に  知ってますよと
こんなもんやと この低次元の楽しみはと
低次元の苦しみはね こんないくつかのループで回転するんだと
ループ覚えておいてください
くーくーくーくーだったら不幸
不楽になって 不幸 不楽でつなげちゃって
つなげると次にまたくーくーくーになっちゃうんです
また不幸 不楽になっちゃってとかね
楽の場合は 楽 楽 楽 楽流れれると不幸
不楽になっちゃって 不幸
不楽で繋がれちゃうと
まあ嫌だ うるさい 苦になっちゃうんです
不幸 不楽の感覚の場合は
不幸 不楽 まあ嫌だ これはと苦になっちゃうんです
それで総合的な計算どうなる？計算してみてください
いろんな楽しみの流れで最終的な答えは何なのかと
苦しみの流れで最終的な答えは何なのかと
不幸 不楽が流れると最終値は何なのか
全部苦なんです だから数学的じゃないでしょう
そういうわけで 私はこの結論を出しましたけど
幸せには決まった値はありませんと言ったのは
今の説明ではないんです
あの まあ言わなくてもすぐにわかりますから
この感覚が苦ですか？楽ですか？と決まった値で判断するんじゃなくて
前に聞いた感覚で判断するんです
いつでもただ対照的に見るだけ
ちょっとしたスティックを上げて
これは長いですか 短いですか？と皆様に聞いちゃうと
皆様に答えられなくなっちゃうんです
頭がいい人だったら 頭が悪い人だったら
これは短い もう一つ いえ
長いというか もうその場合は何か頭の中で基準があるんです
だから頭の中に何か基準があって
それに比較すると短い
あるいはそれに比較すると長い
で 自分が前に持っていたイメージによって答えが出てくるんです
イメージ持たない人は
長いか短いかって言ったって答えられませんよと
答えられません 答えが一緒だったら
対照的に何か値を上げてくださいと
30センチより長いか短いかとかね
そうすると30センチを対照的に比較することができます
見せたスティックは31センチだったら長いという 90
トゥエンティーナイン
えっとえっと  29センチだったら短いという
そういうわけです 幸せも同じことで対照的です
相対的です ですから 私は苦だと思うものに
他人が楽 不苦楽に決まります
私は楽だと思っているのに
他が苦だと思う あり得るでしょ
この法則を日常経験で発見してください
これは日常経験に持ってきたんで
皆様が自分が幸せと思うんだけど
相手がそう思っていない場合
いくらでもあります それで夫婦喧嘩になっちゃうんですね
その場合は主なケースは男が幸せだと思っているんです
女の人は幸せじゃないと思っているんです
まあとにかく大げさなことじゃないんだから
まあ普通 人は様々 また打ち間違い
好き嫌いは様々 好みは様々
なぜ様々になったかというと
このちょっと瞬間前の感覚によりますよ
これも それも大したことない
自分の主観的な判断は他に強いて強いている
強いることは どういうことかと
私は判断しないでハテナで終わっちゃったんで
自分で判断してくださいと
これ相当私に個人的な迷惑なんですよ
時々これ美味しいんだから食べなさいって言っちゃう
いい加減にしろよと これ本人に美味しいんだからって
私に美味しくなるくならないか別でしょうに
時々これ健康にいいんだからって
別に健康を心配しないんだったら面倒くさいんですよ
だから自分の判断を他人に強いるっていうことはよくやってますからね
これは合理的な生き方じゃない
だからトラブっちゃうんです
これ わかってる人は気をつけるでしょ
それで一つのチャプターが終わりました
次 デフォルトの判断基準
どんどん難しくなりますよ
この話は 今まで説明したのは
ほんのちょっと前の感覚
ほんのちょっとつまらないなと思っていた時
友達が遊びにでも行こうかなと聞いてくれちゃうと楽しくなっちゃう
あ じゃあ行こうかなと
だから その時判断基準はほんのちょっと前の気分なんですね
しかし デフォルトの基準もあります
自分の希望通りに幸福にならないんですね
だからデフォルトの基準があって
これ邪魔するんです このデフォルトは業です
好き嫌い 幸福 苦楽の判断基準に個人差がありますね
個人差があります 似ている可能性はありますが
同一にはなりません 我々は人間だから
ご飯を食べておいしい
おいしい おいしいやと言うんだけど
なんだか似ているような気がします
だって人間ご飯食べるんだから
草食べませんだからね
でも牛同士だったら草に対しておいしい
おいしいと言うでしょうね
しかし 人間一人一人がおいしいと感じることは違うんです
あれ 微妙に似ているところで誤解しないでください
おにぎりで喜びを感じる人も
豪華な弁当なのに満足しない人もいます
何でも楽しく取る人も
嫌だと思う人もいる これデフォルトが見えてきますよ
例えば おにぎり 1個食べちゃって
ああ よかった おいしかったと楽しがってる人を見て
豪華な弁当を食べたのに
なんだこんなもんなって思う人もいる
その人 いつだってそんな調子なんですね
いつでも何か文句を言う
何か何かケチをつける人いるでしょ
だからその人はいつだって何か苦しみを感じているんですね
いつでも明るく 何があっても
まあまあ いいや いいや
大丈夫 大丈夫だというふうな人もいるでしょ
明るく あれは前説明した瞬間の話とはちょっと違うでしょう
これがデフォルトというんです
ですから あの人のように明るくなりたい
幸せになりたいとは決してなり立てない
なんか自分にデフォルトで判断基準一つついてるんです
これ取り除けないんです
これは仏教で業というんです
それで私たちは世間を見て
あの人みたいに明るくなりたいなとか
やめてください そんなのは
その人のデフォルトなんです
それは 余計な苦しみの原因になる
業の力で説明します 業の力で生まれる
苦楽の判断基準は業によって設定される
業っていうのは この生命を生かせるエネルギーなんですね
生命を生む 生かする すべて管理するんです
ただのエネルギーですよ
心にあるんです だから
何かしらの生命で生まれたら
その生命がこの幸福 不楽を判断しなくては生きていられない
だから はい これは体温だからね
こういうふうに判断してください
と 手本くれます これは赤ちゃんでお腹で妊娠する瞬間で出て持ってくるんです
テキスト 幸福判断の それで赤ちゃんたちを見たらね
泣きっぱなしの赤ちゃんがいて
ほとんどニコニコと笑っている赤ちゃんがいて
機嫌が悪くなったらなかなか直らない赤ちゃんがいて
機嫌が悪くなってもすぐ立ち直る赤ちゃんがいて
チェックしてください
特に赤ちゃんっていうのはすごい研究材料になりますよ
世の中のこと何も知らないでしょ
でも 生まれたばかりの赤ちゃんも
自分のデフォルトの判断基準を持っています
これはあの 仏教はすべて無常だと言うんだから
この生まれてきた時持ってきた基準
デフォルトの基準 それで我々は明るい人間
暗い人間 嫉妬が嫉妬深い人間とかね
いろいろ言うでしょ 性格分析するでしょ
性格分析とは 業のデフォルトのことなんです
それがすべて無常だから
変化しないわけじゃないんです
変化したければ真理を学ばなくちゃいけない
この地理学を学んだってもできません
数学を学んだってもダメです
真理 命のことを学ばなくちゃいけない
真理とは仏教になります
それから戒を守る 道徳的に生きる
いくらなんでも 道徳を守って生きていると
デフォルトの基準が 手本はまた書き換えられちゃうんです
業によって訂正されます
だから暗い人間に明るい人間になれます
それは自分で自分の業のテキストを書き換えなくちゃ
訂正しなくちゃいけないんです
あの人のようになりたいなりたいと思っても
ひどい目に遭うだけで
さらにダメになっちゃうんです
それで改改良することはできますし
改悪することもできます
生まれつき持ってきた
皆様の言葉に入れましょう
運命 運命って仏教的には使わないんです
これは科学的な単語じゃないんです
皆様にわかるのは非科学的な単語だから
まあそれ仮に使いましょう
もって生まれた運命を改良することも可能
改悪することも可能 世の中をよく見ると
改良する人っていうのはすごい少ない
改悪する人間っていうのはいくらでもいる
だからほとんどの人間が生まれた時定めた幸福には達しないんです
改悪するんです だから勉強する能力があっても遊ぶ
貪瞋痴に負ける 欲に負ける
誘惑に負ける それで道徳を守らない
悪いことをする 万引きをしたり
学校で喧嘩したり なんかやっちゃう
そうすると あのデフォルトのテキスト
また訂正されます より悪くなるようにと
だからここで自由がないんです
ブッダに説かれた生命論を学ばなくちゃいけない
それはブッダは仏教ではないんです
これは真理です 一切生命はこういう法則で生きているということで
それから正しい方は 仏教用語で言えば戒律になりますけど
道徳ですね これは決まりですから
どうしようもないんです
道徳的に生きていなくちゃいけない
犬であっても猫であっても
いくらか道徳的になるとすごい幸せになりますよ
人は幸福を目指して様々な道を歩む
芸術家に 科学者に サラリーマンになりたいとかね
仕事に行かず家に閉じこもりたいとかね
各個人の業のこういうのは
各個人の業がそういう指令しているんです
時々大学も卒業しているんだけど
会社に 1週間ぐらい行って辞めちゃう
もう行かない だから感情に負けちゃって
自分の業を改良しようと
その努力はない あ 嫌です
行って 1週間で上司に怒鳴られたんだから
なんであそこに怒鳴られて
そんな嫌な気分で私は一生いたくないんだと
バカでしょ？一生上司怒鳴られるわけないでしょうに
そういうことで この音楽家になりたい
ああしたい 子供たちよく聞いてみて
子供が大きくなったら何するの？と聞いたら
みんないろいろ夢言っちゃうでしょうに
まあその時はまあまあ
業の指令か 時々業の指令でない場合もあります
何か見て気に入ったものを言っちゃう場合もあります
その時 そんなに真面目じゃないんです
皆様も大人だから 小さい時からこうなりたい
こうなりたいことはあったと思いますよ
あるいは逆にようわからないという風に曖昧で生きてきた人々もいる
なるようになりますと
音楽家になりたいと決めた人は
もうそれ世界でいろいろいじって試してみて
なれる可能性もあります
なりたいんだけど 面倒くさいと言って辞める人もいる
それは一応デフォルトの業なんですね
はい これで一応基本的な我々の幸福不幸の世界について
仏教の立場から説明して終わります
もっと難しくします で
テーマは 幸せはなぜ美味しいんですかね
楽を目指す法則を発見しましょう
ある法則があるんです
なんか我々はロボットみたいにやられてるんですよ
幸せを目指しなさいとか
この法則を発見しましょう
ないものだから欲しがる
当たり前 苦不満感じるから楽を期待する
あるものは期待しないでしょうに
だから至って簡単な話
あんた幸せになりたい？なりたいよっていうことは
裏に何があるんですかね
今は幸せじゃないってことでしょう
今楽であっても 例えば今は楽を感じている
それでも納得いかない
不満 満足できない まあ今はまあ悪くはないんだけど
これぐらいでは満足できませんと
仕事もあって給料も入るんだけど
こんな程度の給料ではね
そうするとさらに幸福を目指すんです
だから今苦だったら 当然ないものねだりで幸福を期待する
今苦ではないんだけど
不満 こんな程度では納得いきませんという人も
もうさらに期待する 楽であっても
それは消えるから 一定しないから
さらに楽を欲しがる もう一つ
楽しみっていうのは一定しないんですよ
例えば好きな音楽家がいて
この好きな音楽家の曲を聴くとすっごい感動するとします
だったらね 四六時中その音楽家の曲を聴けばいいでしょ
一定しないんですよ ある時間聴いてると嫌になってくるんですね
だから別なことをやりたくなるんです
例えば 映画を見ることはすごい趣味で楽しいんだと思う人にとっても
映画ばっかり見ていられないんですね
ものすごく嫌になっちゃうんです
ということで 我々にはもう偏見的で
何か音楽好き 映画好きとかね
読書好きとか何かあるかもしれませんだけど
これも一定しない 読書が好きな人でも
もうある時間本を読んでいると
ああ もう疲れちゃもう嫌だということになってしまうんです
というわけで 別な楽しみを探す必要が生じるんです
答え簡単 あんた幸せじゃないんだから
幸せを探ってるんだよと
だから幸せもどきの幸せのようなものをやってはいるんですよ
ね かっこいい服を買ったり
おいしいご飯を食べたり
まあ勉強したり旅行したりやってはいるんだけど
それ何やっても満足に至らないんですね
あるいは飽きちゃって
慣れてしまって 例えばホテルなんかに1日泊まるとすごい楽しいんです 3
日続けて泊まってみてください
すごく嫌になるんです
はい 次のポイントに行きます
苦聖諦 ドゥッカアリエサッチャ
これはもう普通日常の苦しみの話じゃないんです
お釈迦様が悟りで発見した真理なんです
生きることは苦なのに気づかない
生きることは何か探すことでしょう
何か取り入れる 生まれてすぐ呼吸を取り入れる
呼吸を取り入れるんじゃない
空気を取り入れる でなきゃ死んじゃいますね
それからおっぱいを取り入れる
母乳を取り入れる 取り入れなかったら生きていられないんですね
だから吸わなくてはいけない
空気を吸わなくてはいけないという苦しみがなければ
呼吸しません 母乳を飲まなくてはいけないという苦しみがなかったら
母乳を吸いません 赤ちゃんが自分の体でものすごく不自由不安を感じるんですよ
すごい恐怖感を感じるんです
だから母親の体にべったりついてるんです
この体についていけば大丈夫だと
だから赤ちゃんがあんなにお母さんに依存するのは
自分に苦しみがあるからなんです
問題はそれに気づかない
赤ちゃん気づかなくてもいいんだけど
なんで大人はそれに気づかないんですかね
この気づかないことに仏教用語で無明と言うんです
楽な感覚に執着して 苦を避けて楽を目指す生き方になる
ですから 我々は楽を目指そう
楽を目指そうばっかりになるんですね
赤ちゃんでも一人ぼっちでいるとすごい寂しくて怖いなあとかね
それも実感した方がいいのに
でお母さんが来て体を触って抱っこすると安心するんだとかね
そうやって順番で理解すればいいのに
そこで我々は何やるのかというと
色声香味触法から楽を探すが
それは無常で不完全で
納得できる楽を与えることは不可能です
そこでまた最初に戻って考えてください
我々は楽をどこから得るのかというと
色声香味触法から得ようとしているんです
美味しいものを食べることで
美しい音を聴くことで
気持ちのいいものを体に触る
触れる 触れることで いろんなくだらないことを考えることで
楽を探しているのです
幸福を眼耳鼻舌身に色声香味触法を触れて
楽な感覚を作ろうということが人間の生き方なんです
でも問題は 目に触れるものは無常です
目に触れるものには 決して我々を満足させることはできません
耳に触れる音は無常です
満足して聴覚を作ることはできません
瞬間満足したっても 音は消えますよ
で 満足がなくなっちゃうんです
人間が色声香味触法を追っていくんですね
すべて無常で その色声香味触法には
仏教の仏教用語で言えば世界
世間から楽を幸福を得ようとしているのです
でも世間が無常なんです
世間にはほんのわずかな楽を与えることはできます
でも我々を満足させることはできません
世間が無常で 世間とは色声香味触法なんです
考える場合は 世間はもう心の中なんですけどね
それでも外の世界だと仏教はするんです
外の世界 こういうことで仕方がない
みんなハメられている状態になるんですね
はい 次のポイントはこの期待
希望 願望なんですね こう不満があるからあるという証拠です
あんた何か期待がある？と言ったら
ありますよとかね 何か願望でもある？と言って
みんな持ってますね 結構
ということは あんた不満ですね
だって願望があるんだから
でしょ？だから今私は不満であるということの証拠は
何か期待することある？何か希望がある？じゃあ私に聞かないでください
聞いちゃうと期待外れの答えが来るんです
私の答え決まっていて
あなたがいない方がいいと期待していますよと
ですから さっさと帰ってくださいと
唯一の希望はそれやと
聞きたくないよ そんな言葉は
でも まあ一般的なまとめな人間なら
こういうことを期待しています
こういうことを期待していますとかね
なるんですね ということは
今すでに何か不満を感じている
乱れな思考 妄想で期待が膨張する
これが一番危険なところですよ
例えば 子供が勉強してほしいと
程度の希望はそんなに問題を起こしません
旦那日曜日ぐらいちょっと家のことを手伝ってくれた方がいいんじゃない？とかね
その程度の期待希望はまあ大きな問題にはならないんです
まあそれでも叶わない希望ですけどね
遊ぶ時間やめて ちょっと勉強にその時間入れた方がいいなとうちの子は思ってもやってくれませんよ
でも危険な期待じゃないんですね
危険な危険な願望じゃないんです
だから危険でないまとめな願望でさえうまくいかない
その上 私たちは妄想するんです
ある人を見る 見たら なんてきれいな人だなと感動する
いわゆる楽が生まれちゃったんです
それで私も こんなに美しい人間になりたいなと思っちゃうんですね
バカでしょ この肉体変えられませんだから
業が作った肉体だから
あれって立派な妄想でしょう
あるいは人の歌を聞いている
舞台でもう感動する あの声量には
私もこんなにして ああいう風に歌っちゃいなとかね
そういう風に妄想してしまうんです
これって楽しみの元じゃなくて
苦しみの元なんです それで我々は一人ぼっちで妄想すると
いろんなことを妄想するはするは
この妄想からあらゆる期待
願望が現れてくる この膨張することはとても危険で
自己破壊の道になります
さらに苦しみが増えて
楽を探す探しに必死になる
そうやって妄想のせいで
我々はもうあらゆる期待
願望を作っちゃって ものすごい不幸になるんです
だから皆様方は勘違いで期待あれば
願望があれば幸せでしょうと逆なんです
幸福な人には期待ないんです
もう幸福だから すごい楽なんです
だから我々は期待 願望を乗り越える生き方を探さなくちゃあかんです
期待にやられない 願望にやられない生き方を探さなくちゃあかんです
感じる不満も探す幸せも
思考妄想によって違います
だからまた人間様々バラバラになっちゃうんですね
一人一人が勝手なことを妄想するんだから
一人一人の幸福感 探すものはそれぞれ勝手で変わってしまうんです
それで期待は失望します
さらに苦しむんです 希望
願望の妄想は現実できない場合
現実的であっても生消生消励めない場合
失望の苦しみが現れる
期待があったら失望の苦しみが待っている
これって余計でしょ 例えば私は年寄りだから体から弱い
足がかなり何回もこけそうになっちゃったんです
これは苦しみですけど
まあ当然で そんなに大げさなことじゃないんです
だから余計じゃない 避けられない苦ですね
それを理解すれば まあ手すりをつかまった方がいいやと
そんな程度で終わります
我々はそういう常識範囲を飛ばしちゃって苦しんでいるんです
それは希望 願望から現れるんです
努力する人も 楽を感じるために苦を経験しなくてはいけません
例えば 希望がある 希望を叶うと努力もする
でも希望を叶う努力は苦しいでしょう
希望が叶ったんで その時は楽しいんです
それは否定できません
東大に入ろうという希望をする
ただでは入れませんね
ハチャメチャ勉強しなくちゃあかん
で ハチャメチャマンネリ的なことを暗記したりして
勉強して で 楽しい勉強でもないし
で なさらば東大は知識人は期待してないんです
自分で物事を考える人は嫌なんです
だからロボットが欲しいんだからね
だからそうやっていっぱいものを覚えて
もう吐き出せる人間が合格します
だからそういう勉強は気持ち悪いんです
自分で考えて 自分で想像して
いろいろ自分でインスピレーション的にいろんなことをやりながら勉強することはすごい楽しいんです
その人はもう東大に入れません
フリーシンカーだったら入りません
でもフリーシンカーが楽しいでしょ
それで東大に入ろうと希望したら
その人はそのなりに頑張るんですよ
あの頑張る道が苦しいんですよ
しかし 合格したら当然楽しいんです
あ 合格しちゃったよとかね
その楽しみはもう OK です
OK ではなくて 否定しませんよ
問題は希望叶ったら楽しいんだけど
あの道は希望まで行く道が苦しいでしょうね
だからこれ引き算しなくちゃあかんでしょうに
どんな程度楽しいかと
まあ心の声だから引き算できませんだけど
そこである人が東大に入りたいと思う
しかし 楽しく生活する
友達と遊んだりして 授業中でもあまり真面目に聞いてない
で 俺は東大に入ってるぞと思ってるんです
で その人怠けてるでしょ
それで入るわけないでしょ
そこで希望を失ったって不幸になる
しかし その子には勉強しなくちゃ
ガリ勉しなくちゃいけないっていう苦しみはなかったんだけど
結局は苦しい結果で終わっちゃうんです
希望を失ったっていう
これで生命の法則になっているんです
楽から楽へという道はありませんね
これでワンセクション終わり
一応ちょうど半分ぐらい終わりましたから
ちょっと休憩いたします
で 終わったところは あの
楽から楽っていう道がありませんということなんですが
これもあの精密に仏道ではないんだけど
まあ普通的普通にの生き方はやっぱり楽から楽はありません
質問ありましたけどね
だからあの 苦しいだ 頑張りたくないと思っている人は
苦しみに潰されてしまって
不幸から不幸へと転がっていくんですね
だから幸福になりたい人は
それなりの道を歩まなくちゃいけない
それが楽な道じゃないんです
楽な道じゃないんだからといって
幸福になって悪くはないでしょ
あの東大の例なんか出したのはそういうわけなんですね
東大に入るために勉強することは苦しいんだけど
合格したら楽しいんです
だからどう見ても常識的には正しく計画的にこう味わいながら幸福を目指さなくちゃいけないんです
で 仏教はものすごく怠けることっていうのはとんでもない悪だと
八正道に正精進という項目があるんですよ
解脱 悟り 究極の幸福っていうのは
正精進 正しく精進することでしか成り立たないんです
ただで降ってこないんです
これは極端な無知な連中が言っていることです
神様が与えてくれると
与えてくれません 何も
この宇宙法則では 一人一人の努力で幸せになるんです
そういうことで 私もよく面倒くさいんです
時々瞑想する方々は妄想が出るんだけど
なんか妄想をなくす楽な方法ない？とかね
30 分座っていると足が痛いんだから
座る瞑想をやめてもいいんじゃない？とかね
もう腹が立ちますよ もう
いつでも裏技聞くんですよ
解脱に達する こんな心理と遊べないんですよ
病気の人に この天からもらった薬だよと言って
ミネラルウォーターいっぱい飲ませたっても病気は治りません
カニングして試験を受けたってもね
意味がないんです だからこのカニングの仕方を聞いている人々は
この楽から楽の道があると勘違いしているんです
瞑想も楽じゃないんですよ
一つ楽じゃ 我々 私の生き方
楽だと思う 決して楽じゃないんです
一つも楽じゃないんです
でも気にしない いろいろもう前前に前へ進んで生きてみるんです
はい 次のセクションに行きます
幸せを如実に見る 観察する
悲観主義 楽観主義を超えて
だから この幸福論では
みんな西洋の頭イカれていっている学者が
今日もある人の講演 講演会
授業を聞いていたんで
ネットで アメリカ人か分かりませんだけど
1時間ぐらい仏教の悪口を言うわ言うわ
もうキリスト教基準で喋ってるんで
結構勉強してる人ですけどね
まあかなりやってます
この人は 結構儲かっていると思いますけど
ぶん殴りたくなった このアホやと
でも 仏教ではこの生きることは苦だと言っていることで
この仏教は悲観主義やとかね
そんなことくだらない
悲観主義 楽観主義 すべて間違いでしょ
言ったでしょうに 幸福ってどういうものかと
相対的なものだから 価値って勝手に見れるものだから
だから成り立たんでしょう
吾輩は幸せだと言ったっても
あなた ちょっと前の経験から言ってる話でしょうと
明日どういうかわからないでしょうにと
私はすごい悲しくて 前の気持ちと比較して悲しくなってるだけでしょうに
1時間経っちゃうとどうなるかわからないでしょうに
悲しい人でも  1時間  2時間経っても別のに出逢ってね
超楽しくなる可能性もあるでしょうに
だからこれが流れであって
悲観楽観じゃない だから正しく幸福を見てみましょう
ちょっと早く飛ばします
時間も終わってるんだからね
1 感覚の楽 六根で 楽の感覚を経験しますね
我々が楽しいというのは
この六根 眼耳鼻舌身意で感じて感じたものを楽だとラベル貼ったんです
そうすると楽しいと言うんです
しかし 楽だけの感覚を得られません
これ 例えばお腹が空いている時
一口ご飯を食べると美味しくて楽しいんですよ
このままずっと楽しくいられますかというと
それはないんです  2口目はそれほど楽しくないんです
お腹が 何て言いますか
満たってくるともう楽しくないんですね
だから楽だけで生きていきようかなと思ったら
勘違いのいいところです
喉が渇いてジュース 1口飲む
美味しいんですよ だからってジュース飲めば美味しくて楽しいやっていうことはないんです
それで一口二口飲んじゃうと
もういいってことになっちゃうんですよ
体にも砂糖が入っちゃうし
それで血液に砂糖が入っちゃうと
脳がストップかけるんですね
やめなさいと そうするとまずいんです
飲めないんです 楽だ 楽だけにしたければ
努力するという苦を経験しないといけません
だから 人生楽から楽へといきたければ
頑張って苦しんでくださいなんです
五根で感じる楽にはリミットある
もう勉強しましょう あの六根で説明したでしょ
眼耳鼻舌身意 五根っていうのは肉体にある目
耳 鼻 舌と体なんですね
五根は肉体 それにはリミットがあるんです
目から楽しいよ 目から楽しみ得られます
が リミットがあります
耳から聴覚で楽しめます
でもリミットがあります
ベロから舌から楽しみを感じます
リミットを超えると五根の機能が壊れます
壊れます 味覚が失っている方々いますよ
何も感じない なぜかというと
ものすごく塩を入れて
もう強烈な味付けて食べるんですね
日本の料理っていうのは何かマイルドに感じますけど
結構塩を使うんですね
大量に だからこれで味覚がやられます
例えば そんな大げさな話ではなくて
飴玉一個舐めてみましょう
甘くて美味しいでしょ
それやったらもう一個舐めてみてください
もう甘くないんです 感じないんです
リミット超えちゃったんです
この舌と鼻の場合はよくあります
何か嗅いでみたら あ 香りあるなとか
この香りずっとあると感じなくなっちゃうんです
じゃあ皆様 誰かの家に入っちゃうと
すぐ家の香りをガッと感じるんです
いい香りでも臭い香りでもいいんですけどね
じゃあ臭いとしましょう
ある人を入れたら すぐ臭いと感じた
この人々はずっとこの臭みを感じてよくも生きてるなと思ったら
これ勘違い その人々は感じないんです
瞑想の世界ではない限り
いの楽にもリミットがあって
超えると精神が壊れます
では皆様は目耳鼻が壊れるということはそんなに難しい話じゃないでしょ
機能は壊れます あの ずっとヘッドホンで音楽を聴くと
聴覚が失ってしまいます
だからこの気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
それで心も同じなんです
心は二つに分けなくちゃいけない
瞑想して心で楽しみを感じようとするならば
かなりリミットを超えてできます
でもその場合も本当はリミットあるんだけど
我々思うリミットとすごい次元が違うんです
瞑想しない人が本を読んだり
思考したり 妄想したりで楽しもうと思っちゃうと
リミットがあります で
壊れます これは目が見えなくなるよりは危険です
見すぎちゃって視力が失ったと
まあもう他は大丈夫だから
でも妄想しすぎちゃって精神が壊れたら
まあ仕方がない もう終わりですね
やみくもに五欲を楽しむ
妄想 感情の楽しみは依存症があり
やみくもに五欲を楽しむかなとね
よくやることでね 依存するんですね
酒に依存するでしょ いろんな遊びに依存する
パチンコに依存するとかね
あれ パチンコの五欲でしょ
で 音楽 芸術に依存といったら
五欲体を楽しみにしてるんですね
それで依存するんですね
節度を超えると自己破壊になるんです
まず理解しましょう だから
きれいさっぱり楽しみたい
幸福になりたいと言ったっても
それなりに副作用があります
はい この観察のチャプターだから
楽に楽をチェックします
依存にならないように
楽にチェックを入れることは瞑想の一つです
で チェック入れちゃうと依存にならないんです
いたって簡単です これから仏道的な
この副作用のない安穏の世界を紹介しているセクションに入っています
はい どのようにチェックしますかと
楽苦不楽 楽苦不苦不楽に対してメリット
アッサーデ デメリットアーディーナガン
離れることということは自由になること
ニッサーラ を観察して発見します
だからバカにならない
例えば  すごい大量な肉がある
肉料理食べる 肉は美味しい
それはアッサーデですね
結構豪華でごちそう で
美味しくって美味しさを感じる
それはアッサーデですね
メリットですね しかし
肉食っちゃうと 脂肪が溜まって
腸もおかしくなっちゃって
肉には毒性が高いんです
野菜よりは 野菜も各野菜でも自分なりの毒を持ってますけど
いっぱい繊維 あれやこれや持ってるんだから
体に吸収しないままに出すんですね
人間の腸が肉食べるものじゃないんですね
だから我々人間 仕方なく肉食べてますけど
本当はまだまだ進化していないんです
進化っていうのは 1 万年ぐらいかかりますから
だから未だに野菜を受け入れる腸を持ってるんですね
長い腸を持ってるんです
肉食動物の腸が短いんでしょ
だから栄養科取ってさっさと出すんです
はい そういうことでデメリットも考えてみる
この肉ばっかし食ってる人が仏教徒であるならば
さらに考えられる 肉は美味しいんだけど
脂肪が溜まって体に悪影響を与える
これデメリット それだけじゃなくて
私たちはね こんなにむさぼって肉を食べるということは
たくさん生命が命を失わなくちゃいけないと
だから 生命の命を失うことにも原因になると
そこでデメリットのところもちょっと観察する
ニッサーラナっていうのは離れること
こんなにもパクパク食う必要あるんですかね？とかね
これに依存する必要あるんですかね？とかね
というところも考えてみるんですね
そうすると このチェックですよ
これ瞑想なんです 日常経験からスタートすると進みます
日常経験というのは最もこんな難しいことじゃないんです
例えば子供がいる 子供がいると楽しい
それはメリット でも子供は人間だから言うことは聞かない
育てなくちゃいけない
責任がある 悪い人間になっちゃったら
これ 親にとっては大変な悲しみになっちゃうんですね
責任を果たしてないことになる
子供は不幸になると あるいは社会から非難を受けると
ああ これ楽しみだけじゃないんだと
デメリットも考える ニッサラナっていうのは
こいつに私はぺったし執着すると私がやられます
いくらなんて言いますか
手塩をかけて育てても別な人間だよと
だから独立して自由になった方が楽じゃない？と離れることを考えてみる
あまりにも感情的にならない方がよろしいと
それで 3つも考えたことになりますね
だからご飯食べる時でも
お化粧する時でも ちょっとアッサーダ
アーディーでもニッサラナって3つにチェック
チェック チェック入れてみる
うまくいくなんていいんで
どんどんうまくいくようになります
はい 次 なぜ楽幸せを感じる？理性で観察しましょう
なんで我々は楽しいと感じるんですかと
お腹が空いている時 食べる一口のご飯
喉が渇いている時 飲む一口の水
寂しい時 友達からの電話
退屈の時 聴く音楽 見る映画
読む小説 病気が治った時
子供が産んだ後 産んだ時
産む時楽しくないんです
産んだ後 楽しいでしょ
ですから 基本は元は苦です
お産っていうのはすごい苦しいんです
今は切って出すんだからね
不自然ですけどね それは本当は良くないんです
母親の体に良くないし
子供の成長にも良くないんです
だからまあ知らない で
元はこうですよ 借金で悩んでいる人は
金が入ったら楽しくなるように
楽幸せを感じるために対象になる苦が必要です
そうなんですね 苦が必要です
例えばもうあんまりもう金にも困ってなくて
ご飯も食べてる 例えば私に誰かが 1万円をくれる
まあ別にそんな楽しいということはないんです
まあ嫌ではないんだけど
すごい楽しいってことはないんですね
もし私はお金が 1円もなく
2日も食べてない それで 1万円もらうとどれくらい楽しい？舞い上がるほど楽しい
だから 1万円が与えてくれる楽しみの量が苦しみは決めるんです
対象の基準になる苦がなくなることが楽です
そこで我々は楽というのは
この対象になる苦がなくなるんです
3日も食べてない人が 1万円もらったところで
精神的に舞い上がっちゃって
次ご飯買って食べるんですね
そうすると あの苦しみが消える
ああ 幸せ 幸せとその時は思うんですね
だから幸せとは苦がなくなることなんです
それは大丈夫です なぜならば
いつだって苦があるんです
ということは いつだって幸せになれるんです
これで結論です 苦がなくなることは幸せです
別なもの他何もないんです
現実的な苦をなくすんです
それに幸せというんです
あの病気の場合 よくわかりますよ
病気で苦しんでいるときはもうケチはしませんね
どんな高価な治療もするし
どんな難しいこともしても
とにかくあの病気を治したいんですね
病気が治ったら あーよかったということになるんです
楽を得るのではなく 苦をなくす
それでブッダの提案 楽を得るということはやめましょう
そんなのは成り立たない
楽っていい加減な単語ですから
説明したでしょう ですから
現実的な苦があるんだから
これをなくそうと頑張ってください
と 普通ものに依存して楽を得る
得る 苦 得たもの ん？ちょっと何か間違いみたい
得たものを守る苦 得る苦
だからものに依存する場合は
ものを得なくちゃいかんですね
獲得しなくちゃいけない
それは苦しいんです ただではもらえません
例えば 東大卒業という楽を得たければ
受験勉強するという苦を得なくちゃいけない
得る苦があるんですね
それから獲得したものを守らなくちゃいけない
でなきゃ消えてしまいます
知識は別として 得たものがなくなる時の苦というのはセットでついてきます
ものに依存すると これはどんな生命にもあります
得たものは消えますよ
これはものの場合 心配性で明日のためににも蓄えようとする危険があります
心配性だったらね 余計に余計なことを妄想
明日のことを妄想するならば
明日っていうのは無限で
明日 明後日 来年 再来年
10年後  100年後とかいきますからね
これ失敗するとこいつは蓄えるんですよ
これは苦しみですよ いわゆる現実苦はなくせと
それから妄想苦でしょ
明日のこと 将来のこと
まだ経験していない 蓄える危険がありますね
リミットが切れ ものを貯める奴隷になる
そうなってくると このだって明日食べるために
明後日食べるために 10
年後食べるためにとか蓄えちゃうとリミットがなくなっちゃうんですね
だからこの明日に構えるということは
必ずリミットが超えます
だって明日知らないんです
誰だって でも人間だから
将来のことを心配していろいろカラクリやってます
その時はいつでもリミットが来ます
例えば老後のために貯金しましょうと
どれぐらい貯金すればいいんですかね
あんた知ってる？でしたね
まあ普通に老後 普通に老人で生きていて
普通に治療を受けて死ぬならば
これぐらいやと もし寝たきりになったならば
これ決められますかね
もし介護必要だったら
24時間 わからないでしょ
だからそこで人間なら加えるかもしれませんだけど
仏教的に見てください
これやめなさいではなくて
理解してください こちらではリミットが超えちゃって奴隷になっちゃう
例えば収入ある人は金を貯める
貯める 貯める 老後のために
もしかするともうすべて無駄になる可能性
それで奴隷になっちゃうんです
だから苦をなくすことではなく
新たな苦を作ることになっちゃうんですね
ですから 苦をなくす正しい方法があるんです
今の苦だけに気づける
気を付ける 将来は関係ないんです
これまた瞑想です 実践です
今の苦は何なのかと それなくそう
今がお腹が空いているならば食べてください
お腹が空いてないだったらいいんです
別に 晩ご飯食べなくちゃとかね
妄想できる必要ないんです
晩になってますけど 全然お腹が空いてない
体力はあるだったら別に食べる必要ないんで
苦労して 今が足が痛いんだったらなんとかしてください
今頭が痛いんだったらなんとかしてください
あれは現実です 今の苦はいつでも今の苦に対して対応するんでして
それをなくすんです その苦がなくなったら
それで満足を感じてください
これ大事なポイント 今
私はこの幸福になる道を教えているところですよ
もうかなりサイドを過ぎましたけど
皆様は気づかないように言ってるだけ
瞑想や修行と言っちゃうとちょっと変になっちゃいますから
で 例えば私の足が疲れた
それで私はこちらに座る
座ってなんとか楽しみを感じる
苦が消える それだけ 新たな楽しみってポジティブに来たわけじゃないんです
だからこの楽しみってポジティブ的なものじゃなくて
苦というもののなくなることなんです
要するにマイナス苦なんです
マイナス苦に楽という変なポジティブ単語をつけてるだけ
だからあるのは苦ですね
それにマイナス苦 苦は
だから俗世間的な苦楽感覚じゃないんです
俗世間では楽もポジティブ値で苦もポジティブ値なんです
この楽にポジティブ値を与えるところで間違っています
仏教では苦はポジティブ値で
これは引き算でなくすんです
ゼロになるんです 引き算でなくす分には
まあ好みでやれば楽やと言ってください
単語はどうでもいいんです
だからマイナス苦なんです
で 苦はポジティブ値だったら
引いて引いて引いていくとやがてゼロになるでしょ
苦はそれで終わりです
まだ引き算できない 数学じゃないんだからね
引いてもこちらマイナスだから
金ゼロな人から借金百円ちょうだいって言ったってあげられないでしょ
だから数学だったらゼロから10引けますよ
これは観念的 現実的じゃないんです
ゼロから何も引けません
ゼロには仏教用語で何という？空と言うんですね
空ではなくて空 それに達するんです
そこでこの道が気をつけてください
まず私が足が疲れちゃった
それで座る 座ると足の疲れというポジティブ効果がマイナスになるんです
マイナスになったら あーよかったと思ってください
それに仏教用語で知足というんです
パーリ語でサントゥッティと呼んで
そこで喜んでくださいと
あ よかったと 何か得たんじゃなくて
何か消えたんです 椅子に座って何か得たんじゃなくて
立っていた時の疲れが消えたんです
そこで満足してほしい
というか 知足 物ばかり追わないことは小欲アッピッチというんで
日本語ではね 小欲知足というのはセットフレーズになっているんだからね
まあそれも仏教で仏教用語ですよ
物ばかり追うなよと 物は必要なところでやめてください
昼ご飯食べる時は弁当 1個買っていいでしょうに
金があるからって 3個も買う
弁当の場合 その間違い誰もしませんだけど
生活の場合は量知らない
貯めるは貯めるは貯めるは
それだったらあんた不幸になる
ポジティブにさらにポジティブを与えるだけ
マイナスにしないんです
だから小欲知足を実践してほしい
それが幸せです 次 ちょっとややこしい問題与えること
将来を心配するならば
与えるを実行するんです
将来っていうのは知らないんです
でも人間だからやっぱり心配でしょ
そこで仏教的な提案は
では与えるということを実行しましょうと
これがものすごい幅広い意味なんです
俗世間的な意味で取ってはいけません
これはすごい難しい 幅広い意味を持っています
その気になったら実践します
得るポテンシャルが現れるんです
与えるというファンクションで得るというポテンシャルが残るんです
だから与える与えるたびに
自分の心にあるポテンシャルが溜まるんです
このポテンシャルは何かというと
得るポテンシャルなんですね
だから将来どうでもいいんです
必要なものは得ます だから寝たきりになって介護が必要になったらと心配しちゃって
たくさん金貯めたってのも
もう寝たきりになってもう認知症になっちゃうと
自分の金の管理できんだから
あの貯金は関係なくなっちゃうんですね
というわけで 我々は得るポテンシャルを持った方がいいんです
遭難になっても 地震で家が潰れても
得るポテンシャルを持ってる人にとっては大丈夫です
次に必要なものはたらたらっと揃ってくるんです
だから金があったからといってそれはうまく行かないんです
例えば与えることを実行する
例えばがんになった自分が物の見事に一番腕のいいプロの医者に出会うんです
探し回る必要はないんで
病院 病院から病院にと
で そう出会うんです これ日本語で恵みというの言葉なんです
だから将来のくだらないあの計画をやめましょう
将来わからない 将来が歯が抜けるんだから
まあ立派な歯医者さんと仲良しします
今から計画を立てても
将来歯が抜ける可能性も抜けない可能性もある
抜けたとしても あの医者がもう死んでる可能性もある
意味がないんです だからポテンシャルだけ持っている
ポテンシャルだけ持ってると
歯が弱くなってくると
まあ隣いるんじゃないんですかね
いい医者が そういうことで
この恵みというか ついてるっていうのはそういうことなんです
その人は心配する必要はないんです
ボートで海に行ったってもいいんです
海でボートのエンジンが壊れたっても
何のことはなく のこのこそこら辺で漁師さんの大きい船が行くんですよ
行って引っ張るんです
大丈夫です 自分がもうボートをエンジンが壊れちゃったら困りますからとかね
携帯やら連絡やらSOSの信号
モースコードまで覚えても意味がないんです
ですから この与えるということは
この宇宙法則で与えるということで得るポテンシャルが溜まるんです
我々やるべきなのは将来に構えることじゃないんです
得るポテンシャルをもらうことなんです
慈悲喜捨の実践で安定した精神の安らぎを確保する
この私はこの慈悲喜捨の慈悲の瞑想も与える行為にしたいんですね
与える だから何をとは言わない
そこはエックス それは何を入れたってもいいんです
与えることで誰か生命が助けなくちゃいかんです
例えば私にネックレスをお布施したっても
じゃあネックレスはあまりいい例えじゃない
で 私にスカートをお布施
これお布施与える行為じゃないんです
ですから 与えるとは誰かの生命に役に立つことなんです
ですから 犬に与えることも
ミミズに与えることもできます
カラスに与えることもできます
そこで自益者っていうのは
我々は自分だけ良ければいいという
与えるではなくて この奪う恐ろしい精神なんです
奪い取りとか 生命見立てば奪い合って生きているでしょうに
奪う 奪う 奪う これは不幸の生き方
輪廻の生き方 奪うことの反対
与える 与えるということをするんです
そうすると恵み 恵み 恵みになっちゃうんです
空いてる 空いてる 空いてる
何も心配しない 行ったところで空いてるんです
全部 例えば飛行機に乗るときは弁当を持って乗らない
まああの ドメスティックの際は弁当を持って行ったっていいんだけど
普通は外国の飛行機だったら弁当を持って行かないでしょう
乗ったら全部空いてますね
飲み物やら何でもかんでも
そんな感じで ファーストクラスででファーストクラスで飛行機の旅をするような感じなんです
与える人はどこでも恵まれているんです
その場でその場でサービスがちゃんと揃ってくる
だから将来を心配するというくだらない妄想世界がそこで消える
で 今の苦をなくす仕事に励むことができます
それで自益者も与えることなんです
私は幸せでありますようにというのは当然自分のことですね
でも幸福はみんなにあげますと
だからお布施の気持ちで慈悲の瞑想をやってみたらどうですかね
私から他の生命の精神安らぎも期待しますと
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものに悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
生きとし生けるものが安らぎを感じられますように
生きとし生けるものが毎日楽しく過ごせますようにと
どんな単語でもいいんです
それも与える行為なんです
そうすると ものだけではなくて
精神的にも恵まれます
相対の次元を超えましょう
与えることはヒントです
この相対の次元 だって説明したでしょ？楽っていうのは
あんた苦に比較したでしょうと
苦ってのはあんた楽に比較したでしょうにと
だからわからないんでしょうと
あのスティック持ってきて
長いですか？と 短いですかと聞いたら
どんな答えも当てはまりません
正解じゃない 何かに比較しないと
はい この我々は この対照的でないレラティブハピネスから
アブソルют 英語の単語を使っちゃう
アブソルютハピネスに行くんです
アブソルют 日本語すると合わなくなっちゃうんです
絶対的という事象の単語ですからね
だからビヨンドレラティビティと言わなくちゃいかんだけどもね
相対を乗り越えた そのまま幸福
これは与えることにヒントがあるんです
1万円もらうと楽しいが
楽にリミットがあって
金が消えれば幸福が消える
1万円もらっちゃうと楽しいんですよ
幸福ですけど 相対的ですよ
1万円に与えられる幸福が決まっている
それが私の生き方も相対的だから
私の財力によっても与える楽しみが左右されます
同じじゃないんです そこでどうしても 1万円を使わなきゃ
捨てなきゃ幸福は得られません
1万が 1万円があって楽しい
楽しいと思ったって意味がないんです
1万円があって楽しいなのは
1万円を捨てる時なんです
弁当買ったり 何か服を買ったり捨てちゃうんです
それで必要なものをいただいて幸福を感じるんです
だから捨てるイコール与えるなんです
だから幸福を感じたければ捨ててくださいなんです
新車買ったら幸福だと思っちゃうでしょ？違います
迷惑です すごい迷惑です
しかし 新車に乗ってあちら行ったりこちらへ行ったり
毎日会社に行ったり あれやこれやとやる
そうすると幸せを感じる
しかし 新車が新車でなくなっちゃって古くなっていくんです
ということは ピカピカの新車っていうことは捨てなくちゃあかんです
昔 自分の国で面白い現象があったんですよ
人々はこの何とか苦労してこの家を建てて
リビングにいろいろソファとか何とか買って置いておくんですね
で 暑い国だから埃もいっぱいあるし
窓は閉めませんし 窓を閉めても窓の上から空気が通る道を作っているし
だからすごい高いお金で分割払いで買ったソファセットでしょ
これ埃溜まったら それで何するのかというと
丁寧にビニールシートか白い布で全部隠しておくんです
そのまま使わないんです
私みたいな坊主が行ったらさっさと取り外して座ってもらうんだけど
家の連中は座りません
だから古くなっちゃうでしょ
結局は だから捨てなきゃ楽しみが得られませんよ
高価なソファとそんなことどうでもいいんだけど
ドカンと座ってテレビ見ながら見ながら雑誌を読みながら使った方が楽しいんです
私も寺でスリランカね
まあ子供たちやらいろんな人が来るんだから
みんなに座るためにソファセット買ったんです
で  買っておいたら結構色も良くてかっこよくて
それでそこそこ人間座るんだから
猫たちもダーッと来て
じゃあ俺たちも寝てやるぞと
まあどうそうと 時々猫と私と喧嘩になる場合もあります
どけと あいつらがもう手を出すんだから痛いんですね
私はお前どけと で 喧嘩
これでこいつら何やったかというと
ガリガリとやっちゃう
あなた何やるのかと もうもうもう傷だらけ
今はそこで 隣の家ですっごい大きな犬がいて
ちょっと皮膚 皮膚病でちょっと病気があって
ものすごい紫色のを何か薬ありますね
それを塗っちゃったんですね
これ塗っちゃったと こいつは家からサーッと私の部屋に来て
ドキャンとソファの上に寝たんです
それであの色があのシートに入っちゃって
洗っても洗ってもなくならないんです
あれ消せないんです それからあのあれは漂白剤でも入れてみたんだけど
もう効かない 印刷したような感じで
で 私は結局楽しいんです
それでも だって犬さえ俺が寝てやるぞと使ってやるぞと思っているんだから
だからみんな猫たちも犬たちもみんな私
ものは知っているんです
だから何の躊躇も遠慮もなく使っちゃうんです
そこであの相棒にもありますよ
誰も猫も乗らない まあ撃たれたり怒られたりいろいろ
そう書いてきて 私の部屋に来て
ドキャンドキャンとみんな寝ている
はい だからこの 使うと楽しみがあるんです
使うとは捨てることなんです
弁当が美味しいなのは食べたなんです
食べた時なんです 食べたとはもう弁当は終わっちゃったんですもう
もう元に戻らない 永久的に捨てたんです
もったいないと置いといてください
将来のために  1万円を与えたら与えた喜びは消えます
1万円もらったら 少量の幸福が得られます
使ってそれも捨てることなんです
じゃあ別な捨てることをしましょう
ずつ自分が持っている 1万円をあげる
誰かの役に立つようにする
自分で 1万円で買い物をすることも捨てることですけど
自分がその瞬間で物質的なものをもらっちゃったんだから
制限ある賞味期限がある
使用期限がある 幸福にも量がある幸せなんです
人の役に立つようにあげた
人が病気になって薬買えない
いよいよ買ってくださいと薬をとあげる
それでは薬を買って健康になる
それで私が得た幸福感はリミットがないんです
消えません なぜならば
物質的に何も得ていないんです
だから減れないんです
1万円を必要な人に寄付したら
なんか物質でない何か得ているんです
喜びを得ているんです
それはいつだって思い出したらよみがえります
あげた瞬間のあの気持ちを
この間  1週間前でしたっけ
人に 1万円あげて その人薬を買いたくてお金がない
困っていてね まあローメンでしたか
私は薬買ってあげてね
よかったねとかね 思い出した時でも
あの喜びはまたよみがえってくる
そこで与えることにすごい秘密があるでしょ
リミットのない幸福が
これ ごちそう食ってる幸福とはものすごい違います
ちょっと次に早く行きます
この楽しみは残ります
それで残る楽しみが生まれるんです
この無常の世界で では
最終的なセクションに入ります
執着を捨てる生き方 物に依存することをやめてみます
何にも依存しないという世界を得るんです
もうわかったでしょ 与えることで
なんか誰にもどうすることもできない幸福が生まれるんです
私はノートパソコンを買って楽しい
楽しいと思っちゃうと
これ物でしょ 誰かにそれを壊すことできます
盗むこともできます 私は人が薬を買えなくて困っている時は 1万円あげた
これどうやって盗む？私の楽しみ
盗めません ですから この仏教ではこの執着しない
執着という仏教用語を捨てるという仏教用語与える
全部仏教用語なの もう同じ意味なんですね
ただ レベル一般人には与えるといったら
お布施という短い意味で理解する
狭い意味で で 捨てると言っちゃうと
なんか嫌々で執着捨てると言っちゃうと
もっとわからなくなっちゃうんだけど
同じことですよ で これから最終的な幸福論になります
執着は不可能です で バカだから執着するんです
六根六処にいわゆる体ですね
執着しますが すべての現象は無常で
因縁によって起きて因縁によって消えるので
執着は不可能です 目に執着しても目が無常ですよ
執着できん で 何かに執着したっても
それは無常だから どうやって執着するんですかね？できないんですよ
できないのに執着するんだから
無理不可能に挑戦することは正しく観察してやめるんです
だから物は無常や無常は全部消えていくんだ
消えていくんだとかね
それで観察していくと
あ 執着はできんな できるできないんだと発見するんです
執着していた自分が勘違いしていたんだと
今まで執着によって苦しんでいたんだと
だから 1万円に執着する
お腹が空いたまんまですよ
この人は その人は 1万円をねじったまんまで飢え死にになる
意味がないでしょ 結構いるでしょ
財産をねじったままで死んで餓鬼道に落ちる
はい これ徐々に進むもので
一一発ではちょっとできません
一切の執着を一発でなくすことはできません
だから一個一個チェックしなくちゃいけない
で 執着たくさんあります
でもそうするとキリがないでしょ
執着って無制限にあるでしょ
悟れないね それだったら
花に執着捨てましょう
ね じゃあこんなんだったらペットボトルに執着捨てましょうとかね
ボールペンのどこまでやる？だから眼耳鼻舌身でやるんです
眼耳鼻舌身 六つでしょ？目に見えるものに執着しないって
耳に入る音に執着して
だって無常だから 聞く聴覚は無常で
音は無常で そちら何で執着？見る目は無常で
見えるものは無常で 執着成り立たん
そうやって眼耳鼻舌身チェックするんで
そうすると一切の執着を捨てたことになります
執着の経験っていうのは
過去無限にまで上るんです
遡るんです 輪廻転生の世界だから
過去無限 我々は生きてきたんです
ずっと執着して執着してきたんだから
無知が強烈に固定化しているんですね
だからちょっと時間かかりますよ
ちょっとですよ そんなにも長い時間かかるわけじゃないんです
だから眼耳鼻舌身に対する執着をチェックして
捨てる捨てると頑張る
捨てるとしても捨てられない時もあります
で また頑張る そうするとちょびっとだけ捨てられますとかね
映画見ることを テレビ見ること程度は捨てましたと
でも花見には行きますと
いう そういう風に まあでしょう
人間は いつでもヘッドフォンで音楽を聴くのはやめましたと
でも 電車に乗っている時だけは音楽を聴きますと
だから一発ではできないんですね
で そういうふうに徐々に捨てていってください
日常で執着を捨てて得る安らぎ
安穏を経験します これ一番いいの
この安穏を経験してください
捨てたところで何か安穏が生まれるんです
現象の世界から現象でない世界に入ったんです
これは現象のない世界って日本語の単語ないみたいですね
フェノーメナルワールドからノーミナンというものに行くんです
英語の単語で言えば  日本語仏教用語で言えば
現象の世界から空の世界に入っちゃうんです
空はもう無限で 減ることも増えることも
なくすことも不可能 だから何かの執着を捨てたら
なんかすごい楽になってくるんです
その楽を感じてほしい
一切の現象に対する執着がなくなったら
究極の絶対的な安穏が現れます
これ仏教でいう涅槃ですね
何にも執着しない 眼耳鼻舌身にも執着しない
色声香味触法にも執着しない
すべて無常だから はい
次 幸せのランク付け わずかな幸せから究極の安穏まで
ランク 眼耳鼻舌身意で感じる楽な感覚
これは一番低いランクなんです
誰だってそれぐらい幸せ感じてるでしょ
眼耳鼻舌身から楽しみを感じていますよ
一番レベル低いランクなんですね
生命の次元によってレベル
それも例えば犬の眼耳鼻舌身と
で 犬が楽しむことと 我々の眼耳鼻舌身で楽しむこと
これこれ違うんですね
犬の聴覚はいいんだけど
音楽は聴かないね で 我々は音楽まで聴いて楽しむんです
犬が音楽が流れると もう手を耳でこうやって押さえて寝るんです
人間が怖いだからうるさい
やめなさいと言えないしね
とにかく寝るんです だから
それから我々の体も同じで
私の眼耳鼻舌身で感じる楽しみと
他のそれぞれの人の体の体質によって感じる幸せは変わっていくんです
しかし 第1レベルです
それから与える喜び 与えられるものによってランクがあります
与える喜び それは何を与えるのかと
いらないものを与えるとかね
あまり喜びはないんですね
まあいろいろありますね
それから与える喜びのランクっていうのは
与えたものが相手に本当に役に立ったと
その時の喜びが多いんです
そこで与える時は これは仏教的なことで
自分の執着が減ったならば
かなりレベルの高い喜びになるんです
まあ例えば 1万円なら軽く与えられる
で 残りお金は自分には必要なんです
自分が必要と言ったっても
もうちょっとあげましょうと
もっと必要やとこの人にはと
それで自分が何か金にあった執着捨てたんですね
その場合は まあ 1万円ぐらいあげましょうっていうとこと違いますね
皆様の単語で言えば ちょっと無理をするというかね
無理をする単語を使わないでくださいね
無理をすることは善行にならないんです
で 皆さんの理解できるのはその単語だからね
何の痛くも痒くもなく
1万円は何か大事な出来事があって
みんなの募金しているんですね
自分にとっては何の痛くも痒くもない 1
万円をあげられます じゃあ 2万円にしましょうと
そういう場合はちょっと執着が減るんで
その場合はすごいランクが高いんですね
それから慈悲の喜び 慈しみの喜び
すごいランクが高いんです
慈悲喜捨実践するとなんとなく気持ちよくなって
すごい安穏を感じて穏やかになってくるんですね
そちらにもまた細かいランクがあるんです
たくさんあります ただ慈悲を念じただけの幸福と瞑想と真剣にやって
自分という気持ちが消えちゃって
生命と自分が一体であると感じると
それはレベル一番高いんです
そうやってそちらにも幸福のランクがあるんです
それから瞑想する サマーディ瞑想
サマーディ瞑想すると
この五欲から離れるんです
眼耳鼻舌身意 五欲から離れると
心だけ瞑想に集中して軽質感感じるんです
強烈な安穏 軽質感感じる
肉体から離れたんだから
相当広いんです この幸福は
これはかなりの次元を超えた幸福なんです
その場合も五欲から離れるという
それから思考妄想からも離れるということが必要です
五欲から離れて 思考妄想ではなく
瞑想対象だけやっている
それでサマーディが生まれるんです
どうしても捨てることでなければ幸福は成り立たない
それでランクがあります
禅定に八段階あります
これは今時間がないんだから説明できません
次 最後 無常を発見して執着を捨てて得る対照的になれない幸福
安穏 これは究極です 一切無常だから
これを発見する そうすると執着がオートで消える
できませんと それで本当の苦に達するんです
それは最後の究極のこの上のない幸福
安穏なんです 残念ながらこちらにもランクがあります
4つあります このランクを順番に行かなくちゃいけないんです
まあしょうがないんですよ
生まれてすぐ日本語喋れませんからね
徐々に喋っていくんだから
これは法則です はい 正しく対照的な楽から非対照的な安穏までの道は
仏道で仏教で語っているのはそうです
やって 正しく対照的な楽から非対称的な安穏
その時楽という単語を使いません
安穏までこうやって頑張って進んでくださいって道をちゃんと教えるんです
仏教っていうのはその教えなんですね
苦楽の極端を超えた解脱の安らぎを目指しましょう
で 今日の話は終わりです
はい 最後の聖壇に行きます
まず一個一緒にパーリ語で唱えましょう
ドゥッカッパッタ チェニンドゥッカ
バヤッパッタ チェニンバヤ
スーカッパッタ チェニッスーカ
ホントゥ サッデーピ パーニノー
もう一回 ドゥッカッパッタ チェニンドゥッカ
バヤッパッタ チェニンバヤ
スーカッパッタ チェニッスーカ
ホントゥ サッデーピ パーニノー
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますようにとお参りでございます
サーブーサーブーサーブー